each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my great pleasure to introduce
Tran Jagger is a associate professor at
Penn State before that trenta welcome
many years in IBM Research Watson and
try has done many interesting work on
operating system security like the
access control some selinux stuff yeah
so today trans will talk about his
recent work thank you very much okay
thank you wait on thanks everybody for
coming so I'm going to talk about taking
the various system components that exist
now that enforce security policy so
virtual machine monitors as well as
operating systems as well as
applications and trying to put these
things together into some in some
coherent way into a system that can
enforce some well-defined security goals
and hopefully all of this will be
measurable in some sense so we'll be
able to measure whether the goals are
enforced and if they're not enforced you
know where they're not enforced or if
they're enforced based on some risk such
as accepting some bad data in a way that
won't break your program that we can
identify all of those risks and so we
get a comprehensive view of what's going
on so yeah I wanted to say a little
before that so this work is sort of
built up over the last probably seven
eight years based on what I was doing at
Watson and when I was at watts in the
last four years I was prob'ly us as
Crispin was familiar the security
liaison for the IBM Research to the
Linux Technology Center and so we had
some some interactions there a lot of
the examples will be in terms of Linux
the work is basically very Linux focused
but we'll just sort of assume I mean the
problems are the same across different
systems and so we'll just you know use
Linux names to protect the innocent or
something like that or blame the other
guilty so at Penn State we have a
security lab three
faculty in the security lab Patrick
McDaniel and I are the co-directors the
lab and Adam Smith is joined a couple of
years ago Adam one what's called a peek
ace award which is an award for the best
there there more than one but the best
set of NSF career awards so his career
Ward was accepted and it was one of the
best to reward so get a firm handshake
from our president at some point we work
on basically all facets of hosts and
network security except for hardware
security and in addition Adam does
cryptography we focus a lot on system
security that's my main focus and then
patrick has done work on
telecommunication security I've looked
at that mostly from a systems
perspective in terms of language based
security we mostly we aren't developing
so many new language based tools we're
building on on fundamental language
features and trying to do useful things
with those okay my shameless plug for my
book this came out last year so I don't
know if you're familiar Maury gasser has
a book that he wrote 1988 on how to
build a secure system it's out of print
so you have to scrounge around to find
it's actually a pretty interesting book
but it was one of the main principles in
that book on how to build systems was a
thing called a reference monitor and
we'll come back to this today also and
so he described how you would go about
building an entire system including
authentication and other features based
on reference monitor principles and some
others and so my book looks more
specifically at just the reference
monitor principle and how well
individual systems have or have not
achieved the guarantees required of a
reference monitor and if you don't know
what I'm talking about i'll get to it at
some point in the talk and explain it
but anyway it looks at a variety of
systems in a variety of different
operating system mechanisms and and how
they are and are not amenable to the
guarantees are achieving guarantees of a
reference monitor okay so I have a lot
of slides and we have a fair bit of time
but I want to tell you where I'm going
first so you have some idea what to look
for what to ignore and what to focus on
so basically I'm gonna start out talking
about classical information flow so
multi-level security and bye-bye and
that this is you know form the
foundation for computer security
particular in the DoD environment for
you know 35 years or so and in terms of
building what people would consider you
know bulletproof secure systems this has
been the focus of building those systems
that have found one of the foundations
for building those systems that these
policies are really an idealization I'm
going to claim show you why and give you
an idea where we need to go what's going
to come out of that first is that we we
do depend on a lot of application level
policy enforcement so we started out
with some applications outside the OS
doing security enforcement you know
multics had more than one more than two
rings it had more than the OS and the
rest of the system it had several rings
and they assume they'd have other
trusted programs maybe not quite as
trusted but they would still be trusted
whereas for many years we pushed
security in the security community
further and further down into the
operating system and tried to trust less
and laughs but what of course is
happening and you guys see this here is
that there's a lot of security decision
making going on in the application level
and we really need to take that into
account when we're building systems at
large we can't just ignore that so we're
going to look at application level
security and then we're going to look
also at adding the virtual machine
monitor enforcement into the picture so
now we have virtual machine monitors and
operating systems and applications and
of course if we go further we also have
network enforcement as well and
ultimately we'd like to get our head
around all of these things and so I'm
going to talk about what it takes
conceptually and some progress that
we've made on the last slide that's the
really very recent stuff that we're
still sort of formulating and working on
the paper in our head and then I'll have
an earlier piece of work that that
rectifies application particular type of
application security enforcement with
the system that it's running on
automated away okay so here's sort of
what I just spoke about historically we
have the security community looks at hey
we have operating system it enforces the
policy we don't have to depend on the
applications to do anything and what
happened is in the 70s we found that
with multi-level security in fact we
could show that if even if there's a
Trojan horse running in one of these one
of these applications that we could
prevent the operating system policy and
its enforcement mechanisms modulo covert
channels could prevent secrets in the
Trojan horse infected program from
leaking to some other application based
on this mls policy in this enforcement
at the security level and so the bias
seems to go more and more toward pushing
things into the operating system into
really focusing on you know making this
small and making this the full basis for
enforcement in the system and trying to
take anything away from the applications
assuming that we don't trust the
applications things like minimizing the
TCB became maybe over minimizing so what
we have then for these kind of systems
also in the DoD security community were
these these two types of approaches to
security one news much more than the
other secrecy was a much heavier focused
and integrity and and still is so the
policies basically multi-level secrecy
says that we're we're not going to allow
any leakage of secrets to our authorized
principles okay and so we're going to
set up based on clearances and access
classes of objects so that if you're not
cleared to to access certain objects you
won't be able to gain access to that
data bye-bye is just the dual of this
for integrity it says that hey if you
have some some low integrity process
it's not going to be able to receive
it's not going to be able to send
information i should say to a higher
integrity process because that we don't
want that higher integrity process to
depend on the data that it's receiving
from the low integrity
process and so Bible will will try to
prevent this and so both of these
policies are described as information
flow policies and so they get
interpreted in the community this way so
we have for secrecy some secret entity
and it may or may not have a flow to
some other entity and if it happens the
way you configure the system that
there's a mechanism such the secret
system can cause information to flow to
the public system this would be in a
violation of the MLS policy and it's the
basically exactly the same thing just in
Reverse for for Bible Tegrity so if
there's a flow from the low integrity
process to the high integrity process
this would imply a dependency so I mean
there may not actually be a leak a
leakage right you know you do you enter
your password into a program that
program that's receiving a password
that's entered knows the secret password
maybe you're an attacker you don't
really know the secret password so you
enter the password into the program the
program tells you that was the wrong
password well that's actually a leak of
information that's saying hey that
password you entered isn't the right one
and it narrows the space of searching
that you'll have to do for the right one
maybe not very much if you have a you
know a reasonable size password but it
is from an mls perspective a leak of
information similarly you know you have
some high integrity process you know
it's going to provide services such as
changing your password for example and
when you access asked to run that
program you're providing input to that
program from a process that's you know
from a shell or something that's not
necessarily trusted but we still depend
on the password program to do the right
thing but both of these would be
violations to these these policies and
so what you would need is some assured
fully assured evaluated guard process to
make sure it's okay to communicate
between these two parties in both of
these cases and obviously in commercial
systems we don't we don't have such
processes so what we have is a situation
where where you know secrecy that we
have had some six
building systems for the DoD environment
trusted Solaris has been around for a
while which is you know essentially a
commercial system that provides some and
some if provides enforcement of
multi-level security in some in a mostly
general purpose system and now we have
other systems and also enforce the mls
whereas we really haven't had any luck
with integrity so by be' and Clark
Wilson and integrity models and
variations on them are still things that
we're we're toying with how we're going
to make these these work you know you
know we have the Vista model the UAC
model and that gives us a partial view
of by but it doesn't give us the other
end where the trusted process might read
bad stuff but it prevents the bad guy
from from writing up and so we're still
trying to figure out how we're going to
implement integrity in a comprehensive
way that it is practical and so what
happens is we do things like just
trusting the applications or distrusting
the programs to do the right thing and
hope things work out and you know you we
all know the story there okay so what's
an example of some some trusted programs
about the simplest one that that we have
in Linux environment is something called
logrotate and all it does is age logs
okay so that's pretty simple thing but
it's ages logs across the whole system
and because there are a set of logs the
logs may include information from
processes that are processing secret
data and so the logs may contain secret
data and so in SC Linux MLS log rotate
as a trusted program we designate it out
that's trusted trusted to handle secret
data and not leak it too low into low
secrecy processes as well as the program
receives this log data which could also
be from low integrity process it could
be for any process on a Linux system and
we're depending on it not to be
compromised by that log data and so log
rotate is trusted to protect its
integrity okay so it's a trusted program
and it turns out when the selinux folks
identified
are configured their mls system there
were 34 I think at the time i looked at
it which was a couple years ago there
may be more now they're never less and
selinux that's one thing we've learned
is that their Newell's never shrink so
it's always more than whatever it was
when I looked at it so there were 34
processes that were labeled as trusted
and so what was the basis for labeling
these processes trusted was essentially
that we had to trust these process there
wasn't any sort of analysis of these
that they were really doing the right
thing but we we just have to depend on
them and so we're going to have to go
back later and make sure things are okay
and you know keep an eye on them and
this sort of thing but you know we want
to get our head around this a little
better and for integrity it's just you
know it's much much worse they're much
more yes sure so in here I don't see
yeah yeah well the Linux kernel is
included there yeah yeah yeah so linux
kernel is definitely trust it too so
yeah this is probably this isn't a
comprehensive list and definitely the
colonel is part silly well they do have
a label for Colonel too yeah that means
all the drivers well it refers to user
level processes so the processes running
in come some simpatico with the colonel
are our legal blues colonel
let's see so and then for for integrity
you know obviously there are a lot of
client processes email clients and
browsers and so forth that receive low
integrity data and we're expecting them
to do the right thing as well as many
many server processes Network facing
demons you're aware of of course from
app armor and we're expecting this all
to work out and we haven't got our head
around this gotten our head around this
yet so we end up with is this kind of
situation where we have policies being
enforced in the applications as well as
the systems and they're written you know
you certainly the system administrators
have enough trouble configuring a system
policy so we're not necessarily doing a
whole lot of work with application
policy so currently these are separate
and by policy this I could you know it
could be a procedural thing we'd like a
declarative policy but many applications
have procedural mechanisms to enforce
whatever security they have and now we
have virtual machine monitors you know
hurrah we have another layer which is
coarser grain where we can make maybe
better decisions about security and
isolate these bad things that aren't
working so well at the higher layer but
what happens is in many cases is that we
have authority here and we delegate some
authority to the operating system to do
the right thing and then we delegate
some authority to the application so so
we refine the problem a bit but we don't
eliminate the problem we still have
problems that their applications that
are dependent upon to do the right thing
and we still need to do something about
this and we want to get a picture or an
idea in our mind about how all of this
is working together and whether it's all
achieving the security we have in mind
and of course networking is going to is
in the picture as well I'm just not not
talking about it here specifically so
with respect to information flow
policies we've done as a community two
things 1 i've talked about a lot which
is ignoring the exceptions we label it
trusted and we hope for the best we
allow it to receive data we know is
dangerous and we hope for the best or we
go to a policy that's not information
flow aware we just you know information
flow is not working
it's too restrictive and so we we need
to do something else and so we go to
some more access matrix oriented policy
and then we often have problems coming
up with with meaningful security goals
so I mean a parmer probably had one of
the few you know meaningful security
goals in the sense that we want to
combine Network facing demons that's a
security goal saying we want least
privilege is not a security goal
criticisms the SE people as he Linux
people level that it was security gold
wasn't me
okay but the targeted policy is
essentially the same yeah yeah but then
the targeted policy is essentially at
the same certain security goals so yeah
yeah I don't know what to say but I
believe it's a security goal policy has
a very meaningful goal for people
bashing maintain no machines but it's
too dirty for a mathematical purist to
get information flow out of it so well
we try to get information flow out of
some pot of selinux tile policies but
the targeted policy because unconfined
is yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly but we're
going to try to get our head around this
a bit today we'll see how it goes so
what we end up with our systems where we
have incomplete policies policies that
provide some security but don't provide
full full coverage of an information
flow they partially capture it and then
or and or so we may have both we have
also complex policies policies where we
have a lot of a lot of rules and it
becomes challenging for people to figure
out did I do the right thing so if you
have thousands of rules you know is
there one that's wrong this is a you
know a non-trivial problem if you've
ever probably not a lot of selinux
systems here but if you try to
administer them it's you know a very
challenging task so figuring out how to
administer them is what we're we're
going to work toward so in terms of
related work clearly I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on this but there's
clear they're clearly a lot of
applications that enforce access control
I don't think that's a mystery to
anybody databases being the most
well-known atomic mail is just an email
client it's an old system where they
said Oh emails receiving data that we
care about so we want to enforce
security there so it's more of a seminal
thing rather than a system you currently
work with but clearly all of these
programs and many many others enforce
access control and then there are
languages that have yes gave the
audience
irm apps irm what is iron sorry
intellectual rights management how could
I a bunch of names oh yeah I'm drm still
a whole sort of mandatory crypto email
so we get an email did something else as
I RM the email client won't let you
print it or cut and paste it or anything
okay this of course is totally ownable
if you crack your gene button in
principle right right yeah I'm not
really going to get it quite that saw
that far to the systems that i'm looking
at i'm assuming that the administrator
and the user are our have compatible
goal so i'm not going to go as far as as
that those kind of goals but but that
kind of system is appropriate yeah
definitely so you know you're all
familiar with I'm sure Java security and
many other systems have security
mechanisms for their runtimes and of
course languages that have information
flow security built-in that you can
connect to the system such as a jiff and
of course pearl taint tracking and then
what we're seeing recently is work where
the systems developers are trying to get
their head a little bit around what's
going on in the application so we see an
SE Linux community they have policy
servers for the applications as well so
you can sort of bring selinux up to the
applications and then there's a variety
of work in the research community some
of ours and Neely and shake our its own
at suny stonybrook looking at okay we're
depending on applications to make
decisions how do we manage that it's the
the overall security of the system given
that these applications are going to
make specific decisions how do we reason
about system security there and then an
interesting piece of work is this difc
work from stanford and from MIT where
they're allowing applications to create
new labels that the system will be aware
of to delegate those labels to other
processes and then to try to get an idea
of what's going on in the system at
large even you know taking into account
certain things the application can do
what what this doesn't enable us to do
is know what's really going on inside
the application does the application
have the same semantics for the labels
as the system that it's that its
handling and is it are the information
flows within the application compatible
with the information flows that the
system is trying to enforce and do we
really trust the application relative to
some security goals to to to do the
things that it's going to do so you know
if it's making this the applications are
making decisions about delegation and
things like that and do we really want
just because it can communicate with
this other thing we really want it to
delegate this label access to this other
process yes yeah so I'm talking about is
like the Java access control so Java if
you have a you know a class loader and
you're running some program in Java it
can access the underlying file system
and you can write permissions for that
particular set of code or that
particular class loader or code based on
that to access your file system and yet
so you can control code that's been
loaded into the same job of ham yeah
thanks
so ya see sure yes I thank you for being
here so yeah and a lot of programs have
mechanisms for you to describe in your
program what individual threads of
execution can have access to in terms of
resources from the system what files it
can access and sockets and so forth okay
so we're going to look at how these
layers of security that may be deployed
and independent ways maybe have
independent label spaces can be put
together into a way that may mean
something coherent okay so that's
basically what I'm saying here so we're
going to do is we're going to build
we're going to go back to information
flow we're going to start there because
that's really a definition of a goal and
we're going to build a model of system
policies and goals and assess whether
the system consisting of applications
operating systems VMs is really doing
the right thing with respect to the goal
and so the hard part here is going to be
identifying the goals because we don't
have any specific definition of goals
anywhere we have policies and whether
the policies really reflect a goal or
not is ambiguous then we're going to
evaluate the compliance of the policies
with respect to the goal and evaluating
compliance of policies that one policy
does something that another policy
expects is not itself a new problem but
couching it in terms of reference
monitor so that we can ensure that the
enforcement is really being done
according to the guarantees and again
I'll talk about that in a minute that
it's expected of an enforcement
mechanism is is important than new and
then we're going to look at the problem
in in a more general in a general way
look at generating constraints on how
the policies relate to the goals
necessary to evaluate general purpose
systems
okay so I've been working on this stuff
this kind of stuff for a while we've
looked at trusted programs for example
and looking at what it takes to enable
them to enforce security goals in
practical systems and being able to tell
the system hey you know I'm handling
this this untrusted data but I know what
I'm doing in terms of I know i'm
expecting untrusted data and you can
check whether you believe that I'm
handling it in a right way but this is
where I'm doing it so we've made Clark
Wilson integrity practical and loosened
the requirement for full formal
validation in Clark Wilson by only
requiring that programs that receive
some untrusted and put only do so
through limited interfaces that they
declared in the system so the operating
system will only give them the untrusted
input through those interfaces and those
programs must filter them and so you
could check whether you believe that the
filters are acceptable or things like
this but we are explicitly defining in a
way that connects the application to
system where the untrusted data is
coming into the into the application and
so we're doing now actually is looking
at all the places where bad data goes
into trusted programs in a system so
we've written a tool we're just starting
to collect data with it now where we can
find out all of the places where a
program receives data from some some
other program that some other program
can modify that we consider untrusted
and so that you know question is well
how many interfaces are there on a
system that receive untrusted data are
there 10 are there 100 are there a
thousand are there a million so we're
going to get an idea of how many there
are and start to assess also whether
there are commonalities and how
untrusted data is handled right now it
looks you know obviously things like the
classifiers and endorsers or ad hoc how
you handle untrusted data depends on
what your program does but there should
be you know things like type safety you
should handle untrusted data certainly
in a type-safe way so there are some
things some libraries probably that we
can build it can help define how you how
you handle untrusted data and so we can
and programmers can use this across
program so we're trying to get an
understanding of that
and then the other thing we're doing I
mentioned to wait on earlier has to do
with mediating security sensitive
operations so so if you have a program
that supports supposed to enforce the
policy it's supposed to mediate all of
the ways that you can access this unsafe
data and so with I think actually
talking to crispen probably started us
down this path when I when you guys
working on the lsm I asked you you know
well how did you how did you do it you
said well you know or what what whether
you believe yeah yeah I mean you was
there a principle on which it was done
did you know it was correct and you said
of course the correct answer which was
well no we didn't know it was correct so
we built some tools to look at whether
placements of reference monitor hooks
mediated all the security sensitive
operations in the system we've gone from
finding bugs to trying to identify in
code what security sensitive operations
are to now having a mechanism for
automatically modulo some some
annotations placing mediators in code to
do runtime checks to do to locate where
endorsers should be and where to
classify should be and so we have a
prototype that works for java not so
many security hi trust programs deployed
in java that we have source code for
since I don't work for IBM anymore but
and probably you guys have many and see
sharp or something like that that
would be interesting to us but we're now
looking at sea program so we have the
tool starting to work with C programs
you know we have our first
interprocedural analysis going you know
so we're we're getting there so I'm
going to talk about two experiments
though the rest of the day one is taking
a specific kind of program which I'll
call a trusted program so this is a
program that runs on your system that
you're entrusting with some authority to
to process data on your system according
to some security goals and so you want
to be able to take these programs from
packages you want to be able to download
the program verify that you're going to
be able to to that this program is going
to be able to enforce the policy that
the system has in mind when you deploy
it in a mostly automated way
so you'd like to take the package and
when you install it you want to not only
know that you installed the files but
you want to know okay this thing is
going to enforce a system policy every
time it runs so that's what we're going
for for limited programs and then we're
going to try to generalize some of the
ideas that we found here into you know
all programs across virtual machine
monitor operating system and application
layers so this will actually the second
part will actually focus more on virtual
machine monitor and os rather than
applications but the principles are the
same okay so we're going to dig in okay
so basically we have a program and we
want to download this program and it's
going to enforce some policy for the
system and you know when you install it
is it really going to enforce the policy
the system has in mind that's the
question so in our context we're going
to download some linux package on to a
system with a mandatory access control
policy in this case selinux so it could
be you know any kind of package of any
kind of program downloaded onto any
system that enforces mandatory access
control and we're going to verify
whether the program and policy that we
so the program is going to have its own
policy that's going to enforce and so is
that program with that policy going to
enforce the system's policy so that's
the question so what's interesting is
that the package will contain not only
files such as executables libraries data
configurations for that program but also
in this case it's going to contain a
module that's going to extend the system
policy so the system policy exists but
it doesn't know anything about this
program the program may have additional
information that it wants to label and
so it's going to extend the system
policy with that and we want to know
what the implications of that are and
then the program also is going to have
its own policy so it could be a jiff
program which has its own labeling or it
could have a user level reference
monitor of some kind so we've looked at
these two if it you know could be a Java
program with Java monitoring
or C sharp or Ruby or whatever okay so
what's going to happen we hope is that
the program so we want to compose a
program policy that enforces the
system's goals okay that doesn't sound
too bad so we have a program policy we
have a system policy so we want to
generate something in the end that's a
program policy that satisfies the system
security goals and at the bottom
protects the program so if their program
data that have protection requirements
we want to also ensure that it within
the program will make this a little more
concrete in a minute now by system
policy how the system policy is
important is you know clearly the
program has been written in some you
know environment but it doesn't know
what your your data is on your system so
we're going to deploy it on the system
your system is going to have some policy
and we want to know that this policy is
really being enforced by a program that
didn't know about that policy before it
got deployed and then we're going to
extend the system policy so we have an
selinux module for the program or some
policy module it's going to extend the
system policy and we want to know that
this program and we deploy it is going
to be tamper protected on that that
system so why do we want to know these
things you know is seemed a little ad
hoc so we want to know these things
because of this reference monitor
concept ok so this concept was
identified by James Anderson's panel in
the early 70s 1972 they wrote the panel
document there about ten people that
worked on this and they identified these
three requirements for a reference
validation mechanism so reference
validation mechanism being a mechanism
that enforces a security policy so we
have to have complete mediation so you
know every operation that security
sensitive has to be mediated the
reference validation mechanism has to be
tamper protected so we don't want
untrusted processes messing with the
policy or the code right that would
circumvent security so here if we don't
if we have a security sensitive
operation that's not mediated obviously
security
invented if we can mess with the
reference validation mechanism then
obviously we can't enforce anything and
then lastly we want to know that this
thing is actually correct in some way so
the way they stated it was that it was
simple enough to be verified in some
sense they refer to code primarily but
we're also going to look at policy does
the policy that's with this actually
correspond to what we expect so these
are the requirements and so basically
from the early 70s through the mid-80s
this was the driving force behind secure
system design and then it's been sort of
a little more on the periphery for a
while until the early part of this
decade when people like Crispin started
adding code that satisfied these
guarantees or at least work toward these
guarantees I mean it's very hard to
satisfy this last one in a general sense
you have to have a very small system but
work toward these guarantees for
commercial systems so certainly we want
complete mediation certainly we would
let we are aiming for tamper proof in
when we configure this thing and we're
hoping that we're you know we're correct
but you know systems can be somewhat
complex it's hard to assure that in a
formal sense this is what we're aiming
for so complete mediation I'm not really
going to talk about we're going to
assume that the program already has that
and so some techniques that we that
we've worked on such as the automated
placement of security code will work
toward this but we're going to assume
this has been done in some way we'll
have some sign JIP program or something
like that and we can see that it's has
complete mediation so we are going to
test tamper-proof ink we want to know
that the trusted program components that
are downloaded are protected from
untrusted programs and this is a you
know it seems fairly straightforward in
one sense that we we know some trusted
program components we don't really know
how many of them are necessarily need
not to be tampered and how this works on
a particular system and then more so we
don't know what the set of untrusted
programs are maybe the converse what
programs we need to trust in order to
make a tamper-proof
guarantee of our process and then we
want to know in the running program not
only the permissions of the process but
also the program policy protects the
integrity of the program data when it's
been loaded into the program so we're
going to test this and we're going to
test the policy we're going to we want a
method that will ensure that the result
that the program policy were enforcing
in that program does enforce these the
system policy okay and we'd like to do
this automatically so we're going to
build some package and we're going to
build it somewhere maybe here maybe
there you know and we want to then
download it on some specific machine and
so we're going to compose a system
policy that we're going to validate that
there's tamper protection automatically
on that particular machine we're going
to compose a program policy for that
particular machine also that we know
will enforce the system goals and then
you can just run the program run it run
and run it on that particular platform
so it doesn't matter which platform so
so what we found is that both of these
correspond to what are called compliance
tests so that is there's a policy and
then there's some security goal or some
some some requirement and so we want to
do is test whether the policy satisfies
the requirement and so there are two
different tests that we want to do
there's one for tamper-proof enou that
the system policy that includes the new
program prevents on ya fund instead it
permits untrusted subjects as does not
permit it prevents untrusted subjects
from modifying that program so I'll have
to figure out what that what that means
in some concrete terms and then for
verification we want to know that the
program policy enforces the system's
policy and protects the program from
untrusted data that it might use so
these are two policies and two
requirements that can be expressed all
in terms of information flow let me just
go ahead here so we're going to take the
program policies represent them in
information flow terms as well as a
system policy and then we're going to
want to evaluate those policies against
security goals and so the compliance is
defined in
terms of information flow this way where
the flows of one press of one program
are all authorized by the goal okay so
so you have a policy and it has a set of
information flows that are authorized
and the question is whether your goal
also authorizes those flowers and if
there's any flow that's not authorized
by the goal in the program is not
compliant so this is pretty easy to to
test the tricky part is setting up the
problem is coming up with the policy
right I mean because testing it is easy
but you have all of this stuff and you
have these ideas and so the question
then is well how do you know whether
your goal is expressing the right thing
so that you can do the test and how do
you interpret the the flows from the
policy that are relevant to the goal and
so ultimately we're going to talk a bit
about mapping so basically the idea is
we have we have a program policy and the
program policy may include its own
labels that the system is never seen
before and it may provide these with
this selinux module okay it should be
allowed to do that and then the system
has its own labels actually have it
backwards right so this is the system
and this is the application and they
each have their own or no I guess that's
the system yet says underscore T and
this is the application but so the the
system has its own labels and it has
some semantics for what the labels mean
in terms of information flow and the
program has its own labels and it has
its own semantics for what information
flow means there and you can interpret
them separately and we've done this for
a long time right all of these user
level programs databases Java programs
c-sharp programs whatever have their own
policies and they enforce it and it's
sort of the system doesn't know what the
heck's going on in there it's hoping for
the best it's set that bit you can do it
good luck so now here we're going to try
to figure out what the mapping should be
okay so we're going to try to come up
with with basically constraints that
that imply how these individual labels
are mapped and so we want to come up
with constraints that will ultimately as
much as possible give us a full mapping
or at least give us a mapping that
indicates that the combination is
so we don't have to get a complete
mapping write an essay Linux we have
thousands of types we don't need to map
every label in the application to every
selinux type we don't even necessarily
have to map it to one specific type we
just have to map it to types that result
in compliant systems that we can test
compliance and that it works out and
i'll talk more about that general idea
later okay but let's stick I'm jumping
ahead a little bit so let's stick with
this this is more concrete so the basic
intuition of the mapping and we have
paper from using security last year
talks about this intuition but not in as
formula form as all ultimately get to
but the idea is sort of a simple idea
you know what just take sort of the
basic idea that hey the trusted programs
these are programs that are going to run
on your system and you're going to
provide system data to these programs
and you're going to depend on the
trusted programs to do the right thing
every time it runs so these trusted
programs and and it's not supposed to
lower the integrity of any of the data
it receives so from an integrity
standpoint from a Bible standpoint the
trusted programs are higher integrity
than any data they receive so it's a
little counterintuitive that the system
and the system's data is lower integrity
than the application and the
applications data but that's that's
what's that's what's going on and I
think I think that's let me know if you
have any questions about that and so the
idea is then that the program components
must be tamper proof they must not be
modified by anything that's untrusted
and so we're going to define a very
small number of things as small as we
can number of processes basically things
like an it into Linux environments of
the initialization and the install it in
the installer and that's about it so
there eight programs we're going to
identify as trust it and nothing else is
allowed to tamper with these programs
modify any of their files and then the
system policy is in a sense isolated
from the program the program is higher
integrity the flows are you know the
program flows but whatever we're
supposed to do with the system data
that's sort of defined by the system and
we should just be able to plug that in
independently and tell the program hey
this is your policy and force that
system policy that
your policy now and you know make sure
you protect your data from that but just
enforce the system policy please okay so
that's the intuitive idea it's a simple
idea but we're going to talk about
whether it works so the idea is that we
have a so this is the program's view now
so the program is going to in a sense
have have this sort of model where and
really this these are sort of all
templates so it's going to put its stuff
here and high and whatever the system
policy is it's just going to jam it in
the middle and we have this catch-all
for low integrity stuff we haven't
really found anything from the prom
trusted programs that goes there but we
still have it the only exception to this
kind of flow model this is an integrity
graph so these are the high integrity
items so the program stuff can only can
flow to the system stuff but whatever
data is on the system outside the
program data can't flow to the program
and so in this model anything in the
program could flow to the system but
that of course isn't true because you
may have secrets in the in your trusted
program like SSH keys or something like
that so there are a few exceptions that
you may have as high integrity
anti-secrecy and they can't flow down
but that's the basic idea okay and so
for a program like logrotate a simple
little program has some executables and
some configuration files and then it
receives some log files as input we're
going to end up with this kind of
integrity lattice for this program and
so logrotate will have these labels for
these guys and these are higher
integrity than any of the labels for any
of the log file data but whatever the
labels are of the log file data if you
have secret data or I'm talking mainly
about integrity here but whatever the
policy is for the system flows it's
going to enforce that on behalf of the
system you just have to plug it in you
don't have to do anything fancy to map
it together in this particular case okay
so so that's the basic idea and we built
some tools to test this out there's a
tistic paper coming out on the analysis
tool so it takes policies at
used to take jeff policies now it can
take selinux policies for both this guy
and this guy it basically just needs
mandatory access control policies and a
translator to translate those into
information flows so there are a number
of policies that could be supported and
then we define in in the case of the
tech paper a specific mapping manually
but what I'm talking about here today is
generating these mappings automatically
and without manually specifying so this
is a key thing so we want to come up
with mapping constraints now rather than
a specific mapping I mapping of course
the specific mapping is a mapping
constraint and tells you this maps that
maps to that that maps of that but we're
going to come up with higher more
abstract constraints and do the mapping
and then we have a system that will only
load programs when they pass compliance
tests and this was published in UNIX
annual called siesta so the idea is you
build your program and you generate
compliance information and then when
when you give the program to siesta it
will only run that if it passes
compliance tests and of course the estes
configured on a system so that it will
only have you know you can't circumvent
and get some other program loaded that
would be able to get these permissions
without going through siesta so it
becomes a shirt pipeline if you will for
this and so one question is you know
would you want this sort of thing in you
know microsoft style environment would
you want to be able to have individual
programs be able to download them to
your system and configure them relative
to system policies and deploy them with
that authority in an automated way we
have some of these mechanisms we haven't
done it in a completely general sense in
the sense that we've looked at specific
programs one at a time but obviously
you'd like to look at all of the
programs and make sure all of them are
tamper-proof with respect to each other
and and when you add a new program
you're doing the right thing with
respect to that program given the
history of the system so we haven't
haven't fully developed that
that history but all of the pieces are
there to do that sort of thing for these
trusted programs I should emphasize
these are very specific kinds of
programs it won't work for every kind of
program okay but so think about that
okay so what does it take we built this
palms tool and it takes like about four
seconds to go through and evaluate
whether the program is compliant and we
evaluated it on 8 trusted packages we
would have liked to have done more but
we needed selinux policy modules and of
the 34 most of them don't even have
policies explicitly define all the
policy that they enforce its procedural
I mean they're trusted so they must
enforce some policy but 26 of them don't
have trusted packages I presume don't
have I'm sorry I don't have selinux
policy modules so they don't have things
that they define I think I'm over
speaking a little bit that maybe that
they just don't define any new labels
also that would that would be that would
be required of policy modules so in any
event we tested these eight and we found
that the policy was mostly set up
correctly for these trusted programs but
there were still a couple of cases where
any program that was loaded in etsy
could mess with any other program that
was loaded in Etsy and so what we wanted
was each of the programs to be
completely separate and if you spit if
you split a couple of permissions in NC
and for the programs we looked at it
looked like that would be perfectly
feasible these files or being added were
independent for those particular
programs then these these programs would
be isolated from each other yes changing
the
yes yeah exactly so the program in the
package has a configuration file it gets
loaded into the etsy directory and
because it's sort of a pain in the neck
to introduce more labels and all of
these programs are sort of trusted
anyway the ones that load stuff into
etsy but there's you know no reason that
that you know some other programs should
be able to modify this other this log
rotate for example configuration file
right well you could have different
labels for each of the program files
that this is the log rotate
configuration file and so it's in etsy
and it's you know it's just a place so
it doesn't really matter so much where
exactly it is if you're if you're
labeling of that is fine grained enough
and you know making the labeling more
fine-grained is you know obviously
making selinux even more fine-grained
you know they're there believe it or not
they are trying to resist that in some
cases so so it's a but here you know you
may this making this more fine-grained
would enable you to say that this
program is in fact tamper proof except
for the Installer end and a couple of
initialization
yeah yeah and so and not too many people
have really a lot of people have looked
at it but it's you know people came up
with ideas and it seems to work and as
long as we don't have you know it
doesn't cause a specific error then it's
okay but if this program would somehow
get compromised then it can go through
and compromise all the others and vice
versa yes well yeah yeah yeahs there
there are some there are some programs
that i think that have some specialized
etsy files so it maybe isn't everything
at Etsy but it's basically the directory
in all the files in there and may accept
with a couple of exceptions but yes
that's what it's tantamount to okay so
we looked at these specific programs so
I'm running a little behind and and they
have a natural relationship and we use
this to determine mapping constraints
that we could then test compliance on
the program so we could come up with an
automated soup-to-nuts way of deploying
these programs to enforce policy and now
we want to know well is there more you
know is there an approach where we can
leverage this for general purpose
systems and can we determine whether a
system in a broad sense rather than just
a single program is in fact compliant so
that's what we're looking at now and so
we're doing that in looking at the
virtual machine monitor policies in Zen
so recently the Zen community introduced
a reference monitor interface for the
the Xen hypervisor called Zen security
modules excuse me and it I guess we had
done a prototype of this called s height
but they they've generalized this to
cover more security sensitive operations
we made some assumptions about what
operations would be security sensitive
and
type work and they've been more literal
about what security sensitive operations
aren't so they've identified more places
in the kernel and are sorry in the
hypervisor and they have a policy model
which is very similar to the selinux
policy model for that and as hype RS
hype stuff was also supported by this
but we're looking at the flask policy so
flask is in fact a precursor to selinux
so you can think of it as selinux same
kind of policies so we want to determine
if the VMM policy and the policies of
the VMS together and ultimately the
policies of the applications lead to a
system that enforces a security goals
you have in mind so you know you have a
system and it has some VMS right so we
might have a privileged vm that gives
you access to hardware and then you have
some server VMS that might provide
resources to a number of applications
enabling applications to work together
and then you have some applications VMs
user VMs they may be isolated or maybe a
few of them will work together appeared
in as peers and you know you think of
like a cloud environment where you may
have a few VMs that will work together
or may have an isolated vm deployed in
the cloud so we have this kind of system
all of the the VMS have their own
mandatory access control policy and then
within them they have applications that
may enforce policy and may have
authority to do things that protect the
system as well and then all of this is
administered by the x sm flash policy so
the flash policy determines what VMS can
talk to what other VMS ok so yes is
vivian part of
mmhmm yeah so Xen hypervisor is the
virtual machine monitor for his end
system and so it has a policy so it's
going to do things like enforce what VMs
can use the low levels and mechanisms
grant tables and event channels to
communicate with what other VMS and then
you know how memory is distributed among
the VMS and the filesystem and things
like that and so that'll be controlled
by the flask policy and then within the
VMS this will say you know sort of the
normal things about okay this process
can access these files and these files
of course are backed by the you know the
excess m policy whatever the partition
was at the particular we have gotten
this case a vm m has positive become
kind of SS p.m. was as a vm enemies
application was this a curve yeah yeah
yeah so it's essentially the same same
kind of problem and you know this is i
hadn't shown you any of the policies
before but these are the policy so we're
going to look at vm m policies i think
that's what those are yeah and then we
have network policies that connect
communication channels between VMs with
labels on networking is integrated with
selinux in a few different ways and then
mandatory access control within the vm
is using the selinux policy within the
system which is the same kind of policy
that i was just talking about before
with respect to the applications and i'm
not showing any application policies
here and so we have a virtual machine
monitor i think many virtual machines
each of them have mandatory access
control policies and we're going to look
at at whether we have compliance in this
context using information flow based
analysis so obviously this is more
complex we have more policies and more
big policies so each selinux policy
we're using right now is 35 megabytes of
source yeah so you thought Vista was big
yes
the policy was written by hand yea or no
no no no no I'm sorry the the this is
the macro expanded policy so there's a
policy that's smaller than this that was
written by hand it's still fairly
substantial I think we're still
megabytes am I still thinks I'm not sure
exactly but it's still people have been
working on it for a long time thank you
and so basically when a program is
introduced to Linux system that security
relevant somebody comes up with a policy
for that and then that becomes a policy
module now so we can extend the policy
easily and so in these policies I mean
why I've been working with selinux for
many years and what I I haven't said
what I really like about it but I like
about it is they're trying to get their
head around everything that's going on
in the system and so from a measurable
standpoint you need to know every
security relevant decision at some level
hopefully not you know manually you have
to assess that but in a you know you
treat it like an assembly language
here's your assembly language of what's
happening from a security perspective
and hopefully we'll come up with
higher-level tools to assess what's
going on and so we can work at a at this
higher level and so they work at policy
design at a higher level but it's it's
still a fairly low level because it's
per application and and they I'm sure
reuse a lot of the rules from other
applications so if you have a networking
application you'll reuse networking
rules from saw their application so so
there's a fair bit of reuse going on in
that respect but the rules have to be
cut and paste
I can say
and
they have rules that are kind of like
that yes so they have networking rules
where you say okay this is going to have
network access and then that will
generate a bunch of rules for having
network access and it'll it'll generate
the same rules for them not the same but
but you know tweak them across
applications does that mean like will
now we reach into a program someone has
to be there
well these are these are changes at the
at the system level and with respect to
the labels bless you so if you add a new
file you may not have to change the
policy because you can use an existing
label and you say okay well this is a
configuration file so you can say it's
you know configuration and application
team and so you'll have to you know make
sure that it's put together in such a
way so that the package ensures that
it's labeled correctly when its
installed but there are there are
different levels of changes to your
program that and that many of which are
robust okay what if i add a new function
in the poobah my son Bobby the program
and someone you to insert to the checks
within the program exit is that a robot
in that dumb and you currently yeah and
so you just said
and that has part of saying like them
how can make sure here's a policy and
the pool ignorant inserts all the
reference monitor and so the necessary
places so that the policy can be
enforced correctly right now that's a
little different level than what we had
been talking about we had been talked
about the system policy and changes to
the program that would affect the
selinux policy would be at the system
resource level so in terms of files and
networking and this sort of thing but if
you change the program so that you would
need to change how the program enforces
security that's that's within the
program policy and the program hook
placements there aren't that many
programs right now that have hooks which
is why we're working on techniques to
automate them so we have 34 programs
that need to enforce security for mls
many more for integrity and you know the
x server people have been working on
reference monitoring and xserver for a
while and that's fairly mature and then
g cough and d bus and linux also have
reference monitoring explicitly but not
i don't think there might be another
program i'm missing but there aren't
many more so this is a very deliberate
manual task for adding reference
monitoring to two programs specific to
to those programs so those kind of
changes yet will be less robust and so
yeah if those affect the system then
that becomes problematic too if you by
changing the program it won't deploy on
any systems anymore then you have to
change the system policy to that becomes
and then you have changed the VMM policy
to now so we don't want to go there if
we can avoid it then the other issue is
that the goals are ambiguous we don't
know what they are in general we came up
with some for this other case with a
trusted program we're going to have to
come up with some and for a system in
general how are we going to do that so
let's see so how much longer should i
got ten minutes okay okay so so i'm
going to talk about graph isomorphism a
little bit sub graph isomorphism to be
specific and i'm not going to claim that
our problem is np-hard
but what I want to do is ensure that we
understand why the problem is what it is
and and we're going to leverage some
knowledge from looking at isomorphism
and helping us to understand what the
problem is in a general sense so in sub
graph isomorphism you have a graph and
you have another graph and the question
is whether a sub graph of this graph has
the same flows as this graph and what we
this you know intuitively corresponds to
what we're doing it at a certain level
in the sense that hey we want to test
whether this policy is okay so there has
to be a sub graph in here that
corresponds to this and we have to
figure out what a mapping is now it
turns out the mapping problem isn't
exactly the same for four reasons that
I'll talk about later but but the
problem is figuring out hey what's the
mapping between these yes attractiveness
does your graph with a note I Reno the
same well they have a different write
the notes have different semantics there
are different constraints on different
notes so we might you have to enforce
that right right and so that the the
notion of how systems are built will
will advise us and how we can map this
so we won't end up with a pure you know
sub graph isomorphism problem but I just
want to I find it useful to think about
it in terms of thing about okay we need
to come up with a mapping we need to
constrain the possible mappings and and
we need to of course look at this come
up with principles that that we can
they're provable that will show why this
why our problem is not this problem and
looking at it at this level will help us
come up with those principles so why
does it even start to look like this
problem is that the goals you know they
may be in terms of different labels
completely than the policy of course we
want goal label goal policies to be much
simpler than the existing policy so
they're going to be many many more
policy labels in an essay Linux system
then there are in a in our goal at least
we would certainly hope so and the and
what we have with this hierarchical
notion is that one policy labels such as
a label of a vm such as this Dom you
label actually represents
set of labels initially and so we have
layering going on here that we don't
have normally but the layering occludes
maybe what the mapping is between the
this policy the underlying labels and
the the goal line so the good news is
that as we done was indicating we don't
have a completely general problem there
are only certain mappings that are legal
the good news is that that it'll help us
constrain the problem although we don't
yet understand exactly how and why and
the bad news is that the constraints
aren't specified so we we have to sort
of figure them out sort of like we did
with the other program so we have to
mind some constraints we have to figure
out what it what it is that tells us
what they can what possible constraints
are we can determine compliance and
we're going to refine the system so I'll
tell you we're going to take a top down
there's a lot of work that's been done
actually in policy compliance I sort of
surprised because I had you know I work
in policy for a long time and written a
lot of policy papers but I haven't
really come across too many in policy
compliance to like dug into it a bit
more so a lot of people have tried to
test policies but they do what you would
expect to do as a researcher they come
up with the specific mapping between
them themselves manually and they test
them and you know we don't really want
programmers to have to come up with
these mappings for these systems if we
can afford it or if you know we want to
make what they specify high level as
well the goal should be high level
whatever mapping hints are given should
also be high level not labels on
individual variables and programs or
something like that so what we're going
to try to do is utilize the vm system
configuration to infer some security
goals fairly high level goals we're
going to see if we can push those
through all the way to the individual
applications so we're going to use
tamper proof and tamper proofing is good
because tamper-proof ink gives us a
guideline that we can get from the
configuration automatically without in
much information
and if there are specific constraints on
applications on user viens and on how
they communicate those will probably
have to be application derived we'll
have to get some hints about that from
that application programmer I think but
it hopefully can be fairly high level
and then we're going to take a top-down
view I'm saying top-down what I mean
really if you think it a vm m at the
bottom and then the others at the top
what I mean is from the vm m policy
which is coarser grain so i think of it
as big and top down to the individual
applications through the OS to the
applications which i consider at the
bottom because they're finer grain but
what I mean is from vm m to applications
and the result is we don't need to
integrate the policies into a single
information flow graph so i don't have
to take all selinux policies all
application policies all of vm policies
and put them all into one graph and then
analyze it like a sub graph isomorphism
problem in a big general sense we can
work from the top down and deal with the
finer grain problems where we need to
where there's authority that governs
what's going on ok so I'm going to blast
through these sides so the point of this
is we have a formal model for expressing
what are what our system is we can infer
goals in that model I'm just going to
blow through these slides if you don't
mind if you have questions later yeah by
all means ask me and you guys have the
talk to if you want to look at these
slower we can we set a set of possible
mappings for the individual objects
called nodes so we start with VMs as
nodes and were going to refine down to
to whatever the level of granularity is
necessary to determine whether things
are safe so we can figure out and we do
this conservatively figure out what the
possible data is at each individual
place we then have a way of testing
compliance so basically what we're going
to do is push the labels around the
graph so each VM generates labels of its
own data initially and they're going to
be pushed around the graph based on the
flows that are there and we're going to
assess the key thing is identifying
whether a flow between a vm and another
vm is
safe or a note and another node set of
principles really as what a note is
whether it's safe whether it's unsafe so
it violates the goal or whether it's
ambiguous and we can't tell you that is
it may send multiple labels of data to
the receiver the receiver may be on
we'll handle some of them but we don't
know which flows are going where and
we'll have to look at it more carefully
and so we compute basically the closure
of labels pushing them around the graph
we introduce flow constraints so these
are constraints to restrict what data
can be sent where because not all data
can be sent every where and when we find
ambiguous flows we're going to decompose
the nodes so dom0 and selinux are in Zen
rather is a privilege node and it
receives lots of data of lots of labels
and so we need to look at that more
carefully to determine whether it's
secure and so we end up with is this
kind of approach where we start with an
information flow graph we deduce and
apply constraints on the flows and on
the individual mappings between the
nodes or sets of principles we check
compliance if we find safe and unsafe
flows then if we find the whole system
is safe then we're done everything's
cool if we find unsafe flows we need to
fix them resolve them if we find
ambiguous flows then we need to look
more in more detail and so then we
repeat from the beginning with for the
ambiguous principles so we dig down
deeper and deeper yes both under us
tables
yeah so so it's basically we I'll talk
about it in a second let me show you so
so the fact that this works top down is
based on the fact that nodes really
represent equivalence classes of
principles and that these principles all
share an upper bound of flows and they
all share a set of possible mappings and
if we find a safe solution at some level
then it's also safe for any
decomposition and we're working out the
formal proofs for that we have a little
sketch here and it's also the same for
unsafe if it's unsafe at a certain level
it's also going to be unsafe below and
so we only need to look to the level
where we can determine safety or unsafe
tea for resolving issues we'll have to
look at the whole graph resolving is a
much harder problem but I think I have a
slide yeah next slide my own straight
man so we're finding that resolution at
this level because it's an abstract
level in terms of sets of principles and
flows it works out to hey you can you
can deal with the flows reducing what's
been sent or changing what's been sent
or you can as you are asking decompose
the principles I'll talk about I'll get
your question on the next slide I think
and so you have these two choices and
these are what the what what individual
rules and the policy affect these is
what we're going to be gathering and
showing to the the user for resolution
hopefully we can order them in some way
because there may be a lot in a SEO
Linux policy but it looks like looking
at things at a higher level may help
with with suggesting resolutions that we
can search at a higher level and and
then just show them the rules behind
that okay yeah so so what we have so
this is the basically the breakdown so
we start at the VMM level we look at the
x sm flash policy and a network policy
that describes what flows are possible
between VMS our VMS rather i should say
and so this results and with the flow
constraints we infer and the goals we
infer
what ends up happening is that VMs with
authority like dom0 other privileged vm
such as a VT p.m. or server VMS because
they may support multiple clients these
have ambiguity but individual user VMs
that don't have security issues we can
determine whether they're safe and
unsafe right away and so that's a nice
thing so the fact that we're looking at
the at the ones in detail for which
detailed security decisions are made
makes sense and so that's kind of a nice
thing but for ambiguous flows we have to
break it open and so we do is we break
it open at the next level by looking at
the selinux network permission so these
are the permissions that connect the OS
labels to the network so so the idea is
that the mechanism the algorithm that I
showed you before doesn't really tell
you what the decomposition is and we
have some policy for describing it and
so what I'm talking about now is the
policy so we're saying okay let's look
at the OS labels that are connected to
the network and see what kind of things
are going on there and so we found there
is that there are almost no constraints
on a network communication so everybody
can communicate with everybody over the
network and so the question is you know
is that are there should there be more
cases can we encourage the definition of
okay this is I've got this VM and it's
supposed to talk you know it's on a
cloud and it's on a cloud with some
other VMS and so it should only talk to
those specific VMs and so then we could
leverage these firewall policies in
order to constrain the communication so
that we can still prove safety in
environment like cloud where we can't
really now now everything is
communicating with everything and then
for those network facing demons that are
just there that Crispin is so familiar
with that are they're receiving
information from anybody and doing
things on behalf of the whole internet
you know what we'd like to do is is
codify in our system disk this
confinement policy that you guys did an
app armor as the goal that we want and
then see if we can you know leverage
that to keep refining the problem so you
know codify these sorts of things in an
explicit way
if this doesn't work then we're going to
have to look at the OS layer and see
okay you know what's happening at the VA
at the selinux label level and dig into
these a little bit more we're hoping
I've done a fair bit of work on
generating trusted computing basis for
selinux policies so the idea would be to
come up with trusted computing base and
and also we're thinking that in a vm
sense and cloud you have a very specific
application you're trying to deploy on
the vm so there's there's specific stuff
that you really care about and we can
utilize this the focal points to also
help us define okay this is what defines
the integrity as long as this
application is is protected on its
system so all the things the application
depends on and the application itself
maybe form a base that where we're going
to try to protect and then you know
we're going to try to see if we can
protect them from from these guys for
example I'm sure this isn't enough
constraints but this is sort of a
starting point for generating these kind
of constraints and this is the direction
we're going down so our goal is that
will have a top-down iterative
refinement and we'll come up with
techniques for generating these mapping
constraints and generating flow
constraints so that we can understand
what's happening in the policy at large
and that the the solution will be
provably efficient from a top-down
perspective not the full isomorphism
because of the properties of the the
systems at in our formal model
it's essentially an application has
having multiple vehicles for different
physical losses we are still
selections of you have this medicine
she can die now
it's Caitlyn
this problem across so such nature and
create them
collab with that information versus
canada has just defective
yeah we're we're hoping so yeah so right
now we're just looking at one box at a
time but so what we'd like is to say
okay this VM is only talking to other
VMS that communicate at this label and
then something would have to justify
that that that communication is
satisfying some integrity criteria you
know through you know tpms haven't
really caught on but through you know
some kind of integrity verification or
something along those lines yeah you're
thinking on the right path that's that's
where we're trying to go down now we
haven't built this this model yet but
that's that's the direction we're we're
working down but yeah that's exactly the
intuition that we're trying to convey so
that's a good point okay so um I think
we're basically out of time so we have
have a tool for assessing this and it
shows you what flows are ambiguous and
unsafe and then you can crack open the
ambiguous ones and look at what kind of
flows are going on in the within VMs or
within the labels that are ambiguous and
it'll tell you what principles
correspond to those and so forth we have
a system where when a VM image the idea
is the VM image is loaded and say you
know some demon that loads VMs receives
it and it's as well you know I don't
know whether this is compliant with my
system so I'll ask the management vm
here if it's compliant so we'll push the
necessary information up to the demon
that receives it it'll push it into the
compliance checker it'll check whether
it's compliant if it's not compliant
then you know it may get pushed into the
tool to fix it which obviously will then
become manual but if it's all compliant
if everything's cool then you should be
able to just load the thing and so we're
studying you know what defines
compliance in a robust sense because
we're finding you know wallah selinux
macro expanded policies are big there
really aren't a lot of differences among
them you know just a few some rules are
different generally and some of them are
at this
same so we should once we prove that
something is compliant be able to prove
that other things are compliant in you
know if they are in fact compliant with
without involving the policy designers
the only other interest the only other
issue I wanted to make you aware of like
those kind of interesting was you know
the notion of completeness versus
soundness so we want a system that you
know that we want to assess how how it
where it fits on this completeness
soundness notion so a complete system
would indicate no false negatives and
one tell us that you know hey if you
deploy this this way it's going to be
secure whereas soundness tells us okay
there no false positives so it tells us
that there aren't going to be any any
errors that are not real errors and so
obviously if you're familiar with
intrusion detection systems then you
know these are these are issues
especially the false positives come into
play now what we have right now in the
in the real world is a completeness
issue we don't really have all the
constraints we say okay we'll turn on
this bit and we'll trust this program
but we don't really say why we trust it
or or you know yes I've been talking
about what what details justify that
trust so we don't really have
constraints for that that should be
satisfied before you would trust it and
so we have an incompleteness problem and
we're trying to use this kind of view to
help generate a complete enough picture
that you can say something about the
system but we can't really guarantee
that you're going to collect all the
constraints you know if a program
receives data and it's untrusted do we
have enough constraints on how that
program handles that data correctly you
know we'd like to have a very precise
definition that says its handling that
data correctly but we don't have it as a
community yet so so we're we're lacking
there so we're going to work toward this
and we'll be able to use more
constraints as people come up with them
but we're not going to be able to
guarantee completeness on our own so we
are going to try to focus on soundness
because we don't really you know in
these complex policies we start
introducing false positives as we're
looking for errors
really going to be the death of this so
we really have to be very conservative
about this and and look at sound
constraints and only refine things if we
know for sure that this is a legal
refinement and so that that's going to
be a channel in divorce because the you
know the obvious thing would be to start
you know oh it must be that one oh it
wasn't that one you know and then
backtracking but with this kind of
approach that leads to potential
computational issues and and undoes some
of the guarantees were trying to make so
we're definitely targeting sound
constraints and so far we've been ok
there all right so so thanks for
listening to the story here started from
the Bohr's model of the atom I think and
worked our way around so basically we
started with information flow it's an
idealization but as far as a security
goal it's still the most useful one I
think we have at least at a general
level we can apply you know other things
as constraints relative to this and be
able to get our head around the problem
but we need to account for application
level enforcement we can't just ignore
it we have to make it part of the
picture we have to understand what
applications are doing and whether
they're they're satisfying helping us
satisfy the security goals we have in
mind in order to really be able to say
comprehensive things about security and
then we'll have to address all of the
layers once we you know now we have vm
systems so the VMM should help us they
should provide nice coarse grain
boundaries for VMS and we don't have to
depend on the operating system to have
everything all of the data and keep it
all straight but they're still going to
be applications that will have authority
to do things that could break the system
security goals so we need to be able to
do it all the way from the top to the
bottom so so thanks I'll take any
further questions if you have
decomposition of higher levels of
obviously don't really have to think it
lots of these different players for my
children
I thought the operator perspective in
terms of Lima so she can I like to have
policy that's actually have what would
these different players and why so
what's essentially given these different
policies it's all the things got much
more obey the composition essentially
the other one and you bring up an
interesting point composition
composition of policies has been a
problem people worked on in a
theoretical community but they didn't
they found that composition didn't
necessarily lead to security and so we
have to be careful about how we compose
and decompose things I think but maybe
not see essentially
labels can I please an abortive end well
as it flows and applications can always
anything and dr. global policy whether
that's actually thinking does stage yeah
yeah eventually we are going to add the
network underneath and so then you could
have you know multiple machines and I
guess in this case you wouldn't wanna
look at the whole internet but you'd
want to look at the machines that are
connected at least with respect to the
VMS that you're interested in so we
should be able to add another layer that
says okay you know you can have flows
from this machine to that machine of
this subset of vm is on this machine to
that subset of VMS on that machine to
that subset of VMS on that machine and
you know our are we achieve
enlightenment
to be a warrior than any other thing
currently yes
yeah well that the problem is going the
other way i think is getting enough
constraints going up the stack we we
seem to have I mean Network policies are
a bit loose but we seem to have more
people doing network policies and more
experience with Network policies in
terms of firewalls than we do with
application policies and wow how
applications handle data correctly and
so so we haven't tried to get a whole
our whole head around it yet as a
community and you know each of the
layers are sort of handled by different
people with different expertise so
bringing them together is what we're
hoping for but I think the harder
problems will be higher at the
application layer but so we should be
able to do the networking not kind of
way yes people here to do some
verification
of you know whatever different types of
policy there
and then hope for the best sort of is
that these components that are going to
ensure the access control they will do
their job right in future so you said at
that a vm is started you do bunch of
checks and say ok as it is compliant
then you let it go so like it's the the
load time versus runtime kind of
integrity check argument yeah or over we
are working on the enforcement and with
the placement of the reference
monitoring and that sort of thing I
didn't talk about it here so that so
that would affect yeah and clearly as
much as you can prove at load time or at
compile time you know the better off you
will be in in terms of a work so you'd
like to minimize the runtime checking
but I'm sure they'll still be run time
checking so we're working with some
people at Georgia Tech who do vm
introspection and trying to see how how
that will integrate into this sort of
thing to look at you know the runtime
behavior of the system so they've been
looking at it for intrusion detection
and we're trying to look at proving
these these kind of things you know for
the cases we're not sure of can we get
runtime checks for those we haven't done
a whole lot on that front yet but we're
just gathering up information for them
now
thank you very much okay thanks